[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur wanduhr
ich bin gerade auf tour in österreich
und zwar in der hauptstadt wien
hier werde ich die spar akademie
besuchen und sagt geht es hier in diesem
video um eine gute ausbildung dort
werden wir nämlich die azubis also die
lehrlinge so ein bisschen motivieren mit
ihnen sprechen und auch über meine
ausbildung über mein studium erzählen
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen über
murat was hat der eigentlich gelernter
weiß es nicht ganz aber er wird uns
gleich erzählen
wir sind gestern abend schon hier in
wien angekommen und unser erster stopp
war natürlich direkt am wiener
naschmarkt der ist wirklich ganz berühmt
und auch wunder wunderschön und seit dem
jahr 2000 gibt es da auch rechts und
links von diesem ganzen
gastronomiebetriebe da geht es wirklich
die food trends aus aller welt
[Musik]
wir suchen jetzt gerade den
israelischen laden nie da waren wir
schon mal essen da was richtig lecker
und da gehen wir jetzt also musiziert es
ist praktisch so eine katze rechts und
links gastronomie und dann kann man hier
so alles damit man nicht friert und ist
üblich dass wir 20 an dass strache
doch niedergehen
[Musik]
mai
die
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der duft auch mit kommen nach österreich
und ich möchte euch gerne ein bisschen
was über die geschichte von uns erzählen
also wie das ganze angefangen hat wir
werden den examensprüfungen noch die
videos gedreht und geschnitten
ich weiß noch wie ich vor meiner
wichtigsten prüfung vor der
abschlussprüfung
ich habe echt viel lernen müssen und
habe aber einen tag vorher so eine
ostermesse gebacken und dann ging das im
video schief und ich habe gedacht oh
nein jetzt muss ich noch mal beraten und
habe bis mitten in die nacht gebacken
danach gelernt und dadurch die prüfung
auch gut gelaufen aber es war schon eine
harte zeit also habe sie hat sich auch
einfach aus aber sie hat sie auch alles
selber beigebracht ich mal ein video
machen
ein video karten dann die musik rein
machen und alles dafür muss man online
dann müssen halt online tutorials
anschauen haben hat sich bei youtube
angeschaut die ganzen tutorials und hat
sich alles selber beigebracht
so hat das ganze dann angefangen und ich
hab dann mal bei einer fernsehsendung
mitgemacht und es waren alles so dinge
dass der kanal eben auch immer weiter
gewachsen ist die mitarbeiter freunde
also immer wenn mein freund haben wir
nichts zu tun hat haben eingestellt und
das war so wir arbeiten ja irgendwo wo
jeder kreativ sein muss und wenn du
kreativ sein willst brauchst du keine
sorgen und zwar es gibt zwei sorgen kann
man sagen als einmal natürlich
finanzielle sorgen die jemand hat
zukunftssorgen die man hat und natürlich
auch familiäre sorgen die jemand hat und
wenn du kreativ sein müsst dann brauchst
du kannst du keine sorgen haben
du musst dich auf deine arbeit konzern
die muss kreativ sein was wir unseren
freunden abnehmen konnten waren diese
finanziellen sorgen das heißt wir haben
sie gut bezahlt und wir bezahlen sie
immer noch gut bei uns ist es familien
fernsehen das heißt du kannst ein
kleines kind vor unsere videos setzen
wir benutzen keine schimpfwörter
die eltern sollen ihre kinder vor und
sagen guck dir das an dann lernst du
wenigstens was und es ist das was wir
sagen es kommt nicht auf die klicks an
es kommt auf die qualität des contents
alle des filmes an
wir möchten unsere region unterstützen
wir möchten die unternehmen unterstützen
die mit ihrer mitarbeiter fair bezahlen
und ihre steuern auch in unserem land
bezahlen
das ist es auch dass das ist auch dass
inter sprung des spar prinzip dh hier
müsste man versuchen ein local hero zu
sein ihre ämter sparen jeder spar markt
ist ein local hero warum
die gehen dann ruhen im bau von und
sagen du bist doch ein bauer kannst ist
gewiss noch mal gestellt doch euer herr
möchtest du deine aber nicht bei uns im
markt präsentieren und es ist es das
heißt wenn man unternehmen ist hat ist
es nicht nur wichtig viel geld zu
verdienen sondern die region mitzunehmen
die mitarbeiter mit dem die leute an dem
erfolg zu beteiligen
und das ist uns ganz ganz wichtig und
das reden auch nicht unseren zuschauern
also was war für uns klar mit wem
arbeiten wir zusammen in einer familie
unternehmen mit der spar gruppe und wir
haben gedacht interspar ein
familienunternehmen in unternehmen
dessen local hero ist dass der dass der
euch unterstützen ist eine privatschule
die wahnsinn erfolgt die zwei erfolge
auf ihn im leben das einmal der
finanzielle erfolg
ihr werdet euch eins mal merken können
wenn ihr mann mercedes gefahren seid
nach mercedes kommt nicht mehr viel dann
holst du von mir aus auch im ferrari
aber irgendwann hört mal auf wenn jetzt
1000 euro in der tasche hast bist du
glücklich wenn du 2000 hast bestand
jugendlicher normalfall nicht das ist es
ist so und dann gibt es die andere
erfolg das ist der emotionale erfolg der
wirtschaft ist emotional erfolg heißt
leute in seiner umgebung mit
hochzuziehen ist etwas tolles zu tun
wenn die leute zu sally kommen mit ihren
kindern und sagen hey meine tochter hat
acht jahre alt kocht und backt durch
dich was gibt s geniale riss bei uns war
es so in der fünften klasse als ich
selber spielerin war hatte jeder von uns
den englischen namen aussuchen müssen
und dann blieb ein name möglich dass
warfali und dann habe ich das abkommen
dann nämlich sally und mein echter name
also der maßnahme den meine eltern mir
gegeben haben halt ist sarah und dann
haben wir gesagt okay sally das passt
und ab der fünften klasse hat mich jeder
nur noch sally genannt weil auch viele
meinen echten namen nicht aussprechen
könne er zum beispiel kann es auch nicht
ich kann den namen meine eigene frau ich
auch sprecher nicht sagen ich habe da
einen sprachfehler ich kann dass seine
mama vergisst auch mein mann sagt etwas
sagen oder salesforce com sagt einfach
zu vergessen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es geht nicht um das spaß dazu sondern
motivation ist ganz wichtig und
natürlich der gesunde ärgert muss
diszipliniert sein und natürlich auch
vieles dafür tun um den erfolg zu können
ja also wir haben ganz normalen
unterricht begonnen und plötzliches
kassen hermann vortrag hatte und dass
sie von meiner mama kind also mal
erzählt regelmäßig dass sie gerne
gemacht
es war einfach sehr cool zu sehen wie so
was entsteht und also wir müssen was
aufbauen kann so groß werden kann und
das produkt aber interspar strafe gerade
und ich sind die super weil das ein
besonderes machen da wo man einfach
war's okay sie hat es entwickelt und sie
oder genug erfahrung damit und ja ich
finde es gut zusammenarbeiten also sally
und interspar weil beide gehen um den
haupt prinzip über die nachhaltigkeit
alle gehen einfach nicht so wieder
discounter nicht zu verkaufen
obwohl sie eine abonnentenzahl von über
eine million abonnenten haben
konstanz im locker und herzlich sind und
das überrascht das ist nicht jeder
und sie machen eine noch nichts vor man
sieht dass das was sie machen echt ist
ich finde dass sandy und die
konsultation mit war alles super
kooperation ist und eine nachhaltige und
das haben sie auch recht verdient gucken
uns gerade in schulen richtig schön was
mir ganz gut gefällt sind hier die
plakate da sieht man eben nicht zu den
werdegang der einzelnen mitarbeiter und
wie sie eben zum erfolg gekommen sind
steht dann der schluss not und die
karriere und da hat man einfach wirklich
eine ganz tolle motivation für die
schüler die sehen nämlich erhalten sonst
dafür tun und kann dann irgendwann
vielleicht auch marktleiter werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich kein echter käse hier war auch
schade drum dabei sind meine
lebensmittel alle schlecht irgendwann
und so können die jugendlichen einfach
ein bisschen das verkaufen üben und das
argumentieren
[Musik]
als ich in der praxis küche lernen die
lehrlinge dann wie man zum beispiel mit
produkten umgeht dann wird eine
verkostung gemacht die müssen einfach
aber was hier zubereitet haben um zu
wissen wie sie die kunden später in der
filiale eben auch beraten und das wird
hier gemacht und ich finde also es
wahrscheinlich die modernste küche und
die modernste schule in ganz europa kann
man schon sagen oder richtig gut
[Musik]
man ist ja
forchheim
na
das servicegame
ama
mit
[Musik]
frau unterrichtseinheit schon kreativ
war wirklich super interessant dort und
es gibt es auch fragen ich hatte ein
bisschen tränenden augen schafft weil
ich einfach vor
unterrichten posten damit tätig und
vermisse und ein ganz ganz tolles
gespräch mit den jugendlichen und die
sprache denn mir ist wirklich der hammer
also die machen wirklich ganz ganz viel
für ihre lehrlinge und ihr könnt euch
das wirklich durchsetzen dass ihr da
lernen dürfen unsere message dort war
natürlich dass man einfach eine gute
ausbildung und studium macht einfach
einen sicheren job paten steht da kann
man immer noch auf kreatives nebenher
machen und viele treten immer ich werde
jetzt mal youtube star und das ist alles
so einfach aus einfach ist es nicht
und meine grundschulausbildung zum
beispiel hat nur darauf fest dass sie da
sehr weitergebracht letzte mal in das
schlafzimmer in wien ich habe eine
umfrage auf ins programm gemacht wo kann
ich das beste wie das schnitzel essen
zwei vorschläge dazu wissen jetzt hier
im warte im plateau tag denn wir möchten
orden nach total
denn wir möchten sie später gern sacher
torte essen muss ich doch auch hier in
der nähe die decken
und jetzt haben wir einmal mehr steht
als kürzel und einmal tafelspitz besser
hier weltweit guck mal über die karte
[Musik]
so lecker sieht das schon aus also hier
habe ich jetzt das wiener kalbsschnitzel
richtig toll also diese partie hat das
besondere dieses luftige es ist nicht
unbedingt mal nachmachen
der kartoffelsalat sind auch richtig
lecker aus ich nicht so mancher auf dem
teller richtig schön appetit nicht immer
noch im tafel steht also eine suppe die
die einlage und das manchmal zu ungestüm
schrecken oder guten appetit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da haben wir café sacher und jetzt gehen
wir eine sache die probleme mal schauen
ob sie genauso gut ist wie alle immer
frau
ich fühle mich jetzt so ein bisschen wie
kaiserin sissi nur mit dem unterschied
dass ich nicht bis points oder bei hp
das modell der schwabe und jetzt erstmal
hier die originale sachertorte
die gibt es nämlich schon seit 1832 sind
die wurde auch zufällig entdeckt und
zwar war der sache als küchen vertretung
in der küche und hat dieses dessert
kreiert und so wurde die original sacher
torte geboren und es sind exakt 34
arbeitsschritte vom hersteller bis zum
verpacken der torte und man kann es ja
auch in einer holzkiste zu sich nach
hause bestellen
ich bin mal gespannt da steht nämlich
die luftfeuchtigkeit die backstube die
temperatur der zutaten und alles andere
ist sehr sehr wichtig für das gelingen
dieser wäre schon eine hohe erwartung
hier haben wir das gute stück schon mal
richtig lecker aus mit einem schuss
schlagobers seit 1962 gilt es recht dass
nur die torte die hier im hause sacher
produziert wird auch lanzarote genannt
werden darf ich kann sich schätzen dass
die sachertorte wahrscheinlich relativ
süß schmecken wird deswegen habe ich mir
jetzt hier einen türkischen kaffee als
und noch dazu bestellt kuba scharf 75
verklickert älter kam es in thüringen
geht es nicht so dass du nicht kleckern
nicht heirats fähig worin besteht noch
fahren als ich den für dich gekocht habe
also doch meine hand angehalten hat beim
papa haben habe ich auch kaffee und
haben das als rein gesteckt
weil wir dann den kaffee trinkt an
diesen liebesbeweis
ich bin aber ganz ehrlich ok schmeckt
süß saftig
ein leckerer kuchen
berufen schokokuchen halt echt lecker
also darauf diese shows und die
schalltechnisches nicht zu süß ja nicht
zusehen und schön locker auch nicht so
schwer dass ich echt gut ich habe mich
mal gehört dass er nicht so gut
schmecken soll aber sie schmeckt mir
doch tsonga fehlt aber auch wirklich
sehr lecker und die torte aber auch
super lecker hier zu lesen wir mal den
kaffeesatz für euch deckel drauf zu mir
drehen
ob waren und nach dem abkühlen lese ich
mal was in eurer zukunft steht stand
ich sehe ich sehe nur ein ausweg der
ganze wald ist alles dunkel kommt nicht
durch
hier sind kleiner lichtblick hier sind
kleiner lichtblick und hier und hier ist
ein ganz kurzer weg und dieser weg heißt
der ort und seine später sahen das so ja
es gibt den einen weg auf unseren
brauchen war kanal gehen und fertig kur
so ein wie war das ganze war hier und
wir möchten euch den weg
so sieht's aus und dann steht auch drin
das jeden mittwoch freitag und sonntag
geht
münchen er sehr
so schlau ist die ganze last sondern
nicht mehr sich was wünschen und dann
auf der anderen seite wenn es damit
produkte tropfen der tropfen
es wird alles gut
[Musik]
das war echt lecker und jetzt haben wir
noch mal ein bisschen können hier noch
ein bisschen durch die stadt laufen
wir haben echt nur noch ganz ganz kurz
völlig gleich schon weiter zum nächsten
station nämlich nach weil dort die
kuchen messestadt
da gibt es dann gefilmt und das video
drüber echt schade dass wir jetzt schon
verlassen müssen wie echte wunderschön
vor allem die gebäude hier gefallen mir
sehr gut
ihr könnt mir mal schreiben wenn ihr aus
wien kommt oder wenn er schon mal warum
es sich auf jeden fall das nächste mal
hin wenn ich einen besuch
in abstatt
mit
ok dann können wir das erwachsen ich
hoffe ich habe dieses video gefallen was
gerne einen kommentar auf den weg und
wir sehen uns wieder das nächste mal
wir gehen als stoff jetzt rede ich
bevor ihr abschaltet wollte ich noch
bescheid geben diese woche samstag also
am 2
juni 2018 bin ich nämlich in wien da
gibt es eine signierstunde und zwar im
huma eleven das ist ein einkaufszentrum
und wenn ihr vorbeikommen dann freue ich
mich wir sind von 14 bis 16 uhr da quer
weil ich bin auch dabei sagt dass ich
dabei bin vielleicht kommen noch mehr
leute dann wir haben also ich würde mich
sehr freuen denn wir machen jetzt eine
österreich-tour und da starten wir in
wien sind war und ansonsten sind wir
leider nur noch privat unterwegs war
aber wir nehmen alles für euch auf also
wenn ihr vorbei kommt am 2 juni 2008 10
14 16 uhr humor eleven in wien mit barca
spar interspar jetzt ja oder ein anderes
video anschauen ja